Speaker 1: Let's go next to Jason from Mt. Juliet.
Jason from Mt. Juliet. Welcome to the program.
Speaker 2: David Thanks for having me. Pleasure.
I actually wanted to ask you about the tweet from
earlier this week. Sure. That you're getting a
little bit of heat from a little bit. Yeah. Yeah,
a little bit. So I honestly think that overall,
it was pretty. Pretty rough. But at the same time,
you made a very valid point because
there has to be something done beyond
what the typical response has done. Right.
Speaker 1: And let me say, just because you're
here and by the way, you're in Tennessee.
Speaker 2: I am.
Speaker 1: You know what? There have been people
who get like Candace Owens keeps hammering on,
why won't I apologize? It's like, well, listen,
I'm not going to apologize for the statement I
made, which was thoughts and prayers don't
stop school shootings. We need to do more.
However, what I did learn, Jason, is that even
though anyone in my audience, when they see the
tweet, they go, David's not blaming kids for
getting shot. He's blaming the people who don't
do anything other than thoughts and prayers. My
audience gets it. That sarcasm doesn't translate
well, number one, to people who don't already know
me. And number two, to people who might understand
that it's sarcasm, but they want to pretend it's
not in order to attack me rather than talk about
guns. So it still was a learning experience for
me. The sarcasm may not work well in tweets.
Speaker 2: Oh, for sure. I would also say there's
probably a third category there of people who are
typically not terminally online like a lot
of us are. So we understand the humor. We
understand your point because of, you know,
just the discussions we have regularly on the
Internet. Sure. But people who just peruse and
can have somebody like Donald Trump Jr. Kind of.
Echo a sentiment against what we are saying or
what you said to make it look bad is it makes
sense that you got the flak You did. I agree. I
wanted to say that I as somebody from Tennessee,
not originally from here, but who lives here now
and who has a little one who goes to a school very
similar to the one that the tragedy happened
to. Yeah, I think you made a very valid point,
and I wish that my state would do something more
than what we're getting from our representatives.
Speaker 1: I'm with you, Jason.
I'm with you. Appreciate the call.
Speaker 2: And have a go.
Speaker 1: All right, Jason from Tennessee,
Let's take just a very quick break and I'm going
to take more calls. So stay stay with us on the
discord, if you'd still like to get on. We'll
take the quickest of breaks and be right back.